joining me now Tom Holman former acting
director of Immigration and Customs
Enforcement and a Fox News contributor
good to have you here Tom you know I'm
reminded of of what the current
president said during the debate process
because he promised the country
essentially exactly what we're watching
play out today listen to this
I would in fact make sure that there is
we immediately surge the Border all
those people are seeking Asylum they
deserve to be heard that's who we are
we're a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing depression you should
come
you know but then later he said don't
come so what do you make of the
obviously very mixed message here
one lucky he's been all over that from
day one right this this crisis because
of a climate change and it was because
of Trump's destroyed the legal system
then it's because it was seasonal you
know he he's been on the map the bottom
line is the Trump Administration allowed
people to claim Asylum too but they had
to do it from Mexico they were made in
Mexico as a game changer but there's all
this Panic or tunnel 42 they can end it
tonight they can say you know what we're
gonna re-implement the remain in Mexico
program people can still play Asylum but
they're going to wait in Mexico no more
Catch and Release that was a game
changer the Trump Administration the
federal courts have already opined that
it was a legal process we can do that
it's legal we can also reinstitute the
Thursday of country agreement there's a
lot of things this Administration would
do to secure the board but they won't
but you said a very important thing you
said a couple times since the show
started that this is about the Optics
it's about they don't want pictures of
overcrowd facilities that is all they're
concern with the Optics of the crisis
not concerning the crisis so what they
want to do there's already 70 percent of
Agents off the line because workflow so
when title 42 gets dropped and more
people come across they're gonna pull
even more agents offline to process and
release quickly you got to understand
their priority is the process released
quicker so they don't have the Optics of
a crisis rather than doing their
National Security Duty so more agents
off the line means more fat markets
across more magnets die more women
children traffic with the United States
more no respect the terrorist can cross
the border the national security job of
the secretary is put on the put on the
back shelf because they don't want bad
objects they're going to have everybody
processing and releasing yeah I I think
that's very true you know you also see
something interesting that's happening
right now because of this panic and the
chaos they are not saying anything about
the Texas Rangers who are standing
behind razor wire and telling people
they can't cross and I remember and I
know you do when they were outraged at
the white house because of uh Rangers on
Horseback who were preventing people
from crossing the River but today they
seem to be okay with it they're also
okay with pulling people off the streets
which is also happening I'm told uh and
and deporting them through various means
of you know selection so what does that
tell you
well first of all thank God for the
State of Texas governor Adams should be
the Secretary of Homeland Security he's
done more to secure this border than by
this Administration but this
Administration has failed they failed
from day one so they're looking at any
straw they can grab a hold of to say
we're doing enforcement actions as far
as arresting people on the streets
that's not happy because what the DHS
did they announced it a day before they
did it so there's actually Flyers all
over El Paso saying it's going to happen
so they're having trouble even finding
people that was that wasn't an accident
they announced this operation which only
not only put officers at risk because
they gave up operational security they
gave they gave a a 24-hour notice that
people to be off the streets this
Administration it's just it's just in
confidence at the highest level I am
shocked at what's happening right now
Tom thank you very much hi winner Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now